to me it was incredibly
unexpected something that you sort of
dream about and you've grown up watching
other people receive and the Oscar is
awarded to and I was sitting on the end
seat the thing that I was terrified of
was that I'd be rooted to the spot with
nerves so I had this in my head so
intently that the minute they said Peter
Frampton Paul Patterson and Lois Burell
for bra I shot up and made it to the
step and turned around and the boys are
still sitting there with the cameras on
them so I had to go back and then it
suddenly hit me I remember saying to
Alysia Silverstone who presented us with
the award thank you so much for saying
my name so well cuz I mean it's a Dar
thing to say but you're just sort of
overwhelmed by talk I understand why
people burst into tears and and others
you know get out of shopping list and
and read it and then the horror struck
me that the
auditorium is lit so you can see
everyone's face so to actually see all
of these faces staring at you was
something that I wasn't prepared for I
still I thought other than this is very
heavy thank God I don't have to say
anything and I had to calm myself so I
started to search the faces immediately
in front of me and I found Mel and he
looked up and I could see tears starting
to form in his eyes it still makes me
tear now it was absolutely wonderful
John Won male one the picture one but it
was the most magical night it's
something dreams are made of and I
didn't ever think would ever happen to
me